bonsoir nous sommes le vendredi 13 mai
nouvelle édition de votre journal de fin
de semaine merci de nous retrouver sur
tv fil 78 tout de suite les sujets que
nous allons développer au cours de la
prochaine demi heure le département
s'engage pour l'insertion
professionnelle et hier jeudi 12 mai à
versailles pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental des yvelines et de
lagence activité a signé le pacte
territorial d'insertion 2016 2017 il a
également signé trois conventions de
partenariat en faveur de l'insertion des
événements en difficulté avec elle et à
la direction territoriale de pôle emploi
et la caisse d'allocations familiales
nous y reviendrons
quelle est la situation du front
national dans les visibles et nous
pourrons parler notre invité philippe
chevrier il a été récemment démis de ses
fonctions de secrétaire départemental
mais reste membre du parti nous ferons
le point avec lui et comme chaque
vendredi le zapping de l'information
locale depuis lundi avec la mobilisation
contre la loi travail la réélection du
conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ou encore la
première réaction nouveau président de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines à didier guillemot et je
vous le disais en titre le 12 mai à
versailles pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental et de lagence
activity a signé le pacte territorial
d'insertion pour l'année 2016 2017 en
plus de ceux de ce pacte de trois
conventions ont été signées avec l'état
la direction territoriale de pôle emploi
et la caisse d'allocations familiales
à la clé de nombreux emplois pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa mais aussi les
personnes les plus éloignées du monde du
travail
une signature qui marque une continuité
dans la politique du département en
faveur de l'insertion professionnelle et
de la coopération des acteurs locaux de
l'emploi écoutez donc les ivy
d'aujourd'hui connaissent un vrai
problème d'insertion
l'année dernière nous avons créé
l'agencé activités pour avoir l'outil et
c'est tout qui progressivement se met en
place et c'est un outil partenariale
donc c'est un partenariat avec pôle
emploi pôle emploi c'est l'accès à de
l'information l'accès à de la formation
c'est aussi avec la caf la caf qui
administre le rsa mais qui donc à ce
titre nous aide aussi à contrôler le bon
usage de nos fonds et puis c'est
naturellement un partenariat avec
l'ensemble des services de l'état
donc ce que nous allons céder
aujourd'hui ce sont des conventions le
travail pour rendre opérationnels cette
agence activity que vous montre que nous
venons créé on travaille en coopération
depuis un an avec le département avec
activity on a commencé avec seize
conseillers sur l'accompagnement global
cess travailleurs sociaux et là sur
cette convention renouvelle et en plus
on amplifie c'est que six nouveaux
conseillers au 1er juin viennent
rejoindre l'équipe six travailleurs
sociaux complémentaires et on va aller
chercher davantage de force d'action
parce que les dispositifs fonctionnent
on les cultive on les amplifie et là on
est sûr depuis le début du dispositif
après this au retour à l'emploi
éducation à présent chaque année depuis
2003 des centaines d'enfants saint
quentinois participent au projet enfin
en scène un projet musical piloté par
l'association pour la musique de saint
quentin en yvelines afin de faire
découvrir aux enfants la musique
classique et de les faire participer
également un spectacle de haut niveau
artistique
sephora namani elio mosquée wrong
retrouver lierre deux classes de ce2 et
cm2 de l'école régionale de la verrière
pendant leur répétition regarder écouter
d'habitude plutôt sensible à la variété
au rap c'est bien l'opéra l'arche de noé
de benjamin britten que ses enfants
apprennent avec motivation
ils font partie des 300 élèves saint
quentinois retenu cette année pour
participer au projet enfants en scène un
projet piloté depuis 2003 par
l'association pour la musique à saint
quentin en yvelines
en treize ans plus de 4000 élèves ont pu
bénéficier de ce programme pour nous
l'arche de noé n'est pas un sujet
religieux c'est un sujet historique
c'est un mythe fondateur de l'humanité
le déluge existe dans toutes les toutes
les religions dans toutes les cultures
autre but est vraiment de réunir tout le
monde
un il ya beaucoup trop de séparation de
communautés si bien chanté heureux la
musique la sig d'un sentier récente
c'est plus doux c'est plus calme une
heure par semaine depuis début octobre
ces deux classes de l'école régionale de
la verrière s'initie à la musique
classique
ce projet culturel a pour but de faire
participer les enfants à un spectacle
musical de haut niveau artistique et à
des concerts d'initiation de secret d'un
hors caisse on leur explique que leur
instrument ça va être la voix donc on
explique un petit peu commençons à voir
comment la protège comme on utilise donc
ils découvrent toutes les richesses de
leur propre voix des exercices de mise
en col de mise en voix de laxiste de la
naksa sion de concentration et puis par
la musique par la joie de la musique les
faire grandir
au mois de juin les quarante deux
enfants de la verrière rejoindront sur
la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
une centaine d'enfants des écoles de
trappes 45 écoliers élan courtois et 44
élèves ni mon teint ils seront
accompagnés sur scène par de nombreux
artistes dont l'orchestré prométhée et
les solistes de la villedieu
deux représentations sont prévues devant
les parents les 18 et 19 juin prochains
et cinéma présent pas besoin d'aller à
cannes pour apprécier le septième art
direction simplement montigny le
bretonneux
les élèves de première du bac
professionnel électrotechnique de l'ifad
de l'heureuse whaou ont participé à un
atelier pour métrage sur trois jours
guillaume le squer et camille lambert me
rencontrer des apprentis acteurs
réalisateurs mais aussi scénariste
silence ça tourne
huit apprentis électronicien de
l'institut de formation par alternance
robert de l'eau rozoy à montigny le
bretonneux se sont réunis pour la
réalisation de leur court métrage une
création originale de ses élèves de
première et le travail sur le projet
depuis son écriture
-participer par le dialogue d'action les
jeunes cinéastes ne sont pas seuls des
professeurs et professionnels les
encadrent tout au long du projet
cependant ils n'interviennent pas dans
le choix du sujet traité
laissant libre cours aux envies des
étudiants pour ce projet en particulier
ils ont décidé d'aborder le thème des
attentats sous forme d'un huis clos
mon âge qui durent de trois jours sur
des projets et chaque année sur des
groupes et sujet changé
cette année il voulait parler
particulièrement de la religion cet
atelier existe depuis déjà 10 ans aliyev
a dans le cadre des projets pédagogiques
proposés aux élèves
en parallèle de leurs études l'idée
c'est pas nous focaliser sur le métier
mais essayer de proposer des activités
qui en même temps ça fait partie de leur
cursus scolaire et en même temps qu'ils
découvrent quelque chose qu'ils n'ont
pas l'occasion de voir ailleurs le film
ne sera pas visible par le public une
fois fini mais il sera présenté à
différents concours et festivals
de quoi donner l'envié aux étudiants de
se lancer dans la profession grâce je
pense à cet atelier
peut-être que je pourrai continuer dans
cette filière prochaine étape pour les
jeunes artistes le montage il faudra
encore être patient pour la montée des
marches à cannes et parlons politique
à présent nous recevons aujourd'hui en
plateau philippe chevrier bonjour je
vous remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous êtes élu front national et pendant
huit ans secrétaire départemental du
front national dans les yvelines c'est
justement sur ce sujet que nous allons
revenir
vous avez été démis de vos fonctions le
2 mai dernier cas vous avez participé au
rassemblement du 1er mai aux côtés de
jean marie le pen est l'un des derniers
vous donner une conférence de presse à
ce sujet on fait le point aujourd'hui
vous saviez que ces décisions allaient
être accueilli comme ça de la part du
français
non je délire je n'avais reçu aucune
interdiction d'aller à 7 à ce dépôt de
gerbe donc carey statut jeanne d'arc
chose que l'ayant ont fait depuis 40 ans
que marine a fait depuis 20 ans
cette fois-ci rêver changé elle avait
décidé de changer la formule mais elle
n'avait émis aucune interdiction
officielle en tout cas je n'ai reçu
aucun message comme quoi on ne ne
devions pas d'y aller
donc j'ai été très surpris des décisions
qui ont été prises souvent escient
brutal à cet envoi a plus que brutale
oui oui soudaine et brutale vous restez
quand même un membre du parti
oui voilà c'est d'autant plus étonnant
que j'ai toujours eu les félicitations
sur la manière dont j'avais géré les
affaires dans le 78 donc voilà donc je
reste dans le parti bien entendu
j'attends la suite
peut-être qu'il y aura des sanctions
supplémentaires
mais en tout cas de mon point de vue je
j'attends je suis dans l'expectative
alors vous sortez un du groupe fn en
tant que conseil régional et vous allez
au moins vous allez maintenant siéger en
tant que le nombre inscrit absolument
absolument à ça c'est une autre affaire
je ne suis pas très satisfait de la
manière dont le groupe du front national
a donc au conseil régional se comporte à
la fois vis-à-vis de la présidente une
certaine agressivité que j'ai du mal à
comprendre d'autant que nous sommes un
groupe assez petit de 22 élus on aurait
pu en avoir 40 mais enfin le sort a fait
que nous on en a eu que 22 donc nous
revenons au conseil régional les
dossiers nous les connaissons pas très
bien il faut se mettre au courant je
pense qu'un peu de peu de comment dire
de calme et de sérénité
comment dire et de désir d'apprendre
aurait dû imprégné ce démarrage et il
n'a pas été ainsi et d agressivité assez
forte vis-à-vis de valérie pécresse et
pendant les séances des invectives entre
les bancs de la gauche et ceux du front
national
c'est pas tout à fait mon style je sais
pas comme ça que je veux travailler ce
n'est pas une volonté pour vous de vous
dissocier du parti d'un éloigne non non
c'est sûr je suis absolument d'accord
avec le programme
j'ai un petit soucis sur la capacité des
gens qui sont en place pour le mettre en
place je suis pas certain que cette
capacité soit au rendez vous mais le
programme tel qu'il est écrit en tout
cas est tel qu'ils existent sous réserve
qu il change la dent dans les jours qui
viennent avec la présidentielle
actuellement il me convient très bien
je n'ai même pas encore en capacité
c'est marine le pen qui visait non plus
tôt son entourage
plus tôt le bureau exécutif le bureau
politique et les gens qui l'entourent
d'une manière générale je les vois pas
aujourd'hui puisque maintenant les
choses sont sérieuses c'est à dire que
marine le pen vu les erreurs que font à
la fois la droite et la gauche marine le
pen se trouve en position éventuellement
de l'emporter à présidentielle donc là
maintenant on peut se poser la question
de savoir si véritablement ses équipes
ces équipes crs1 son temps sont en
capacité de gouverner la france
parler des arts de la gauche de la
droite pourtant voilà vous parle
également d'une refonte du fn lors de
votre conférence de presse lundi dernier
est ce que selon vous il faut créer un
nouveau parti
après tout ces dissensions un nouveau
parti c'est peut-être aller un petit peu
vite c'est commençons déjà par
libéré le parti actuel je pense que ces
structures sont trop si vous voulez à
l'image de ce qu'était son président à
l'époque comme d'ailleurs les structures
de la vème république sont à l'image du
général de gaulle après évidemment pour
les successeurs ça pose quelques
difficultés pour ceux qui n'ont pas
véritablement toute la légitimité de
celui qui a créé la chose donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
certes il y ait une élection tout à fait
légitime de la présidence absolument
indiscutable est tout à fait
démocratique
mais après dans l'exercice de tous deux
de son pouvoir si vous voulez elle est
amené à désigner les gens du bureau
politique a désigné les gens du bureau
exécutif ont du coup je ne sens pas en
tout cas forcément voulu ou désiré par
les militants et là il s'aligne à un gap
qui se produit est non seulement un gap
mais tout va bien tant que la présidente
ou le président suit un cap très précis
et reste dans cette ligne or aujourd'hui
on voit au front national que c'est pas
tout à fait ça c'est à dire que de la
défense des valeurs fondamentales de la
famille on passe à des déclarations
plutôt en faveur de lgbt
donc il est clair que c'est sur le plan
purement sociétale on peut se poser avec
les militants peuvent se poser des
questions sur notre cv partage
voilà votre votre opinion est qu'il n'ya
pas une ligne directrice je pense qu'on
va commencer à en parler parce que
jusqu'à présent personne n'avait bougé
mais enfin je sens quand même qu'il ya
beaucoup d'insatisfaction donc voilà je
suis premier à bouger je pense qu'il y
en aura d'autres mais puisque vous me
parliez la question de la capacité de
ces gens il y a
une question en particulier qui me
paraît très importante qui dit ce qui
différencie le fonds national d autres
partis c'est la sortie de l'euro or à
partir à mon avis à partir du moment où
vous sortez dehors vous avez vous êtes
élus sur cette orientation de sortir de
l'euro pourquoi faire un référendum
pourquoi prendre six mois pour sortir de
l'euro pour moi c'est clairement une
indication moi qui suis économiste
c'est clairement une indication que on
ne souhaite plus sortir de l'euro car
quand vous êtes élu sur quelque chose
qui est aussi différenciant par rapport
aux autres vous le faites vous êtes très
très zélé ligne de jean marie le pen et
celles de marine le pen j'aimerais qu'on
me reviennent juste sur les événements
donc dieu 1er mai marie christine
arnautu donc vice présidente du front
national également votre compagne et
bruno gollnisch était aussi présent à la
manifestation du 1er mai si la démission
de monsieur gollnisch a été refusé par
la présidente du front national en
revanche marie christine arnautu sera
convoqué devant les instances
disciplinaires du front national il ya
vraiment une volonté de punir d'écarter
ce qui reste quand même fidèle en titane
en régate à bâtir sans bruit je crois
que vous faites une très bonne analyse
oui alors maintenant on verra jusqu'où
les affamés partie peut-être du front
national et qui va peut-être voile à
partir des jeunes alors c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué que ça parce que si
fidèle à jean marie le pen humainement
se veut pas dire que nécessairement ces
personnes sont dans la ligne politique
de jean-marie le pen
en ce qui me concerne personnellement si
j'étais plutôt dans la ligne nouvelle de
marine donc tout ça est un peu plus
compliquée us et c'est plus des
relations à mon avis personnel faut
qu'on fait que notre relation plus à mon
avis si on veut trouver une raison à
tout ça elle est plus d'ordre psychique
que d'ordre politique
ces dissensions entre quand même qu'il
ya un problème dans le parti
je partirai un petit peu max est
difficile en fait peut-être ogm si bas
le parti il n'a pas très bien depuis un
an les adhésions se raréfient
beaucoup de cadres s'en sont beaucoup
d'adhérents sont vont ne renouvellent
pas leurs cotisations
il ne va pas si bien que ça non oui vous
relations aujourd'hui avec marine le pen
l'unique justement existantes pourtant
vous sembliez plutôt proche on a
certaines de ces images qui montrent
qu'on vous avez voilà concert des
reportages vous étiez plutôt à ses côtés
une bonne entente et oui mais il faut
être deux pour ces mais vous savez dans
la vie c'est comme ça bon apparemment ma
tête ne lui revient par actuellement
donc ça changera peut-être si on revient
du côté vraiment plus locale le fait que
vous ayez perdu donc votre pote
sécrétaire départemental que vous
occupiez quand même depuis huit ans
est-ce que cela va remettre en cause le
front national dans les yvelines
ça crée un grave déséquilibre
je pense que ça va pas être si facile
que ça mais bon je souhaite quand même
que ça se passe bien je veux dire ces
équipes c'est un peu moi qui les ai créé
de rien en 2008 donc je suis attaché e
et j'aimerais bien que il continue
continue le travail accompli dans le
cadre du programme tel qu'il est défini
maintenant si le programme change
voilà tout le monde est libre vous savez
qu'il va vous succéder au père de
françoise signaux unis qui est numéro
deux élus à versailles c'est possible
c'est son iphone il ya doute il ya
d'autres candidatures pourquoi pas
affaissé c'est un homme d'expérience bon
voilà donc pourquoi pas mais il ya
d'autres candidats un très bon aussi
c'est révélateur quand même de mettre de
nouvelles têtes bien nouveau changement
peut-être en vue de 2017
oui alors la tête ça suffit pas il faut
qu' il faut que la personne qui soit
nommé soit fédératrice qu'elle sache
accepter éventuellement des gens qui
sont pas forcément de sa ligne politique
parce que 78 et très divers vous le
savez il ya la partie proche de paris
qui est plutôt versaillaise voyez ce que
je veux dire un peu traditionnelle et
puis vous avez partie ment de la ville
et ses trappes
ou alors c'est plutôt beaucoup plus
populaires ce sont deux populations du
front national pour des raisons quand
même un peu différente ça vous échappe
pas qu'ils sont ensemble
bon il faut les fédérer si vous prenez
quelqu'un qui est plutôt de l'un ou de
l'autre
ça va créer quelques problèmes merci à
vue vrillée d'être venu sur le plateau
et d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
questions merci à vous
et comme chaque vendredi nous passons
maintenant à l'essentiel de l'actualité
le zapping des sujets développés dans ce
journal depuis lundi regarder
le g président soirée sans suspense et
sans surprise le 9 mai dernier michel
laugier est réélu président du conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
suite à l'annulation du vote du 9
janvier par le tribunal administratif de
versailles avec 43 voix sur 46 suffrages
exprimés le maire de montigny le poteau
nouveau conte ce poste
une partie des délibérations du mois de
janvier est annulée par le tribunal tout
ça parce que il y avait un filtrage à
l'entrée alors que nous étions dans une
situation d'état d'urgence je trouve
qu'on a perdu beaucoup de temps pour
rien et à certains votes auxquels on n'a
pas participé tout ce qui concerne l
exécutif puisque de nouveaux on en est
exclue cire que l'on considère qu'il ya
des communes qui mérite d'être
représentés avec des vrais délégation
puis aller sous commune et dans
l'actualité locale et nationale
aurore bergé et lui les républicains
dans l'opposition à magny les hameaux à
dénoncer le sexisme dont elle a été
victime elle a déploré sur twitter comme
vous le voyez les remarques déplacées de
ses collègues masculins après la
révélation des accusations contre denis
baupin les faits se seraient déroulés au
lendemain des accusations de harcèlement
sexuel lancées à l'encontre du député
écologiste lors du conseil
d'agglomération de lundi soir dans
lequel elle a siégé
il faut que l'université versailles soit
force de proposition elle l'est déjà
et il faut que institutionnellement
politiquement l'ailé est ce qu portent
des projets vers paris saclay de façon à
ce que paris saclay ce soit aussi le
département des yvelines et l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
la première chose que je vais faire
comme je les aime c'est que je les crée
une taxe force paris saclay en
appliquant les collègues les plus
impliqués dans la dynamique de façon à
ce qu'il y ait une coordination et nous
allons mettre au point une stratégie du
gouvernement qui a annoncé lusage du
49-3 pour faire passer le texte en force
pour les manifestants c'est un déni
total de démocratie
il ya eu un débat parlementaire qui
devait avoir lieu ou du coup le
gouvernement s'est rendu compte qu'il
n'avait pas la majorité au sein de ce
parlement pour faire voter la loi et
malheureusement et badens ils ont choisi
de faire un déni démocratique dans les
yvelines c'est l' agence activity qui a
été désigné comme coordinateur
départemental
l'objectif de ce groupement d'intérêt
public travailler directement avec les
acteurs locaux de l'emploi pour donner
aux yvelinois en parcours d'insertion un
accès à l'emploi durable
c'est d'abord la démarche d'insertion
professionnelle qui nous intéresse
puisque ce sera les attributaires du rsa
yvelinois qui seront prioritaires pour
l'accès aux 7 % d'heures réservé sur le
chantier au un processus d'insertion
cent dix églises à travers toute la
france mais pas encore de temple c'est
aux chaînés qui prend forme d'une
surface de 6000 240 mètres carrés
il pourra accueillir jusqu'à 100 adeptes
par jour il permettra aussi aux
pratiquants de se marier
c'est ici il ya 66 ans dans cette maison
jean monnet rédiger la déclaration
historique que robert schuman à les
adresser à l'europe le 9 mai 1960 un
symbole de l'origine de l'union
européenne qui est venu visiter harlem
désir pour célébrer la fête de l'europe
dimanche 8 mai la france a commémoré le
71e anniversaire de la fin de cette
guerre en 1945
un rendez vous incontournable pour magny
les hameaux et pour ces élèves qui ont
réalisé comme chaque année un livre
infinie à cette occasion ils écrivent
les noms des morts pour la france mme
annick quoi dans un livre qui est
reproduit chaque année l'ancien collège
bergson fermé depuis 2007 va être
détruit à sa place un pôle culturel et
des logements devraient sortir de terre
pour la rentrée 2020 le tout pour un
budget total de 11 millions d'euros en
mai je dis ce qu'il me plaît ce mois-ci
guyancourt donne la parole aux jeunes
pour connaître leurs besoins et les
associer aux décisions de la mairie ce
mardi soir une trentaine de jeunes âgés
de 11 à 25 ans ont répondu à l'appel
ils sont venus assister à la première
consultation publique fermée au public
depuis 2007 la galerie des carrosses
vient de rouvrir grâce au mécénat de la
fondation michelin la surface
d'exposition
a doublé et s'étend à présent sur plus
de 1000 mètres carrés
elle présente l'une des plus importantes
collections de carros d'europe
entièrement restauré et après ce résumé
de la semaine retour de notre séquence
regard de jeunes sur l'actualité comment
les plus jeunes perçoivent l'information
locale mais aussi nationale les réponses
des élèves du collège des saules à
guyancourt sephora namani et arnaud
lebrun
le festival de cannes il se passe en
france et que surtout il ya des stars
qui viennent de tout le monde entier ici
c'est un peu de la pub pour moi festival
de cannes se représente pas toutes les
stars qui viennent au festival on peut
rencontrer nos stars et ne peut on peut
voir les différents films pour pouvoir
savoir c'est lequel le meilleur film
s'il ya des stars qui viennent et que
des fois ils font des concerts ça y
avait toujours aussi de payer pour aller
les voir le cinéma c'est à nous divertit
quand on fait du cinéma on peut un peu
raconté un peu n'importe quoi et
s'exprimer que j'aime bien dans le
cinéma c'est les békés spéciaux et tout
on parle depuis longtemps et ça commence
de plus en plus à poser problème on voit
des changements de temps qui commence
vraiment à être très étrange les saisons
sont quasiment plus respectés c'est ça
devient difficile pour nous quoi ne
semble pas que ça sent pas très bon à
cause des pots d'échappement aussi par
exemple un jose et aller à la mer et
quand je suis rentré chez moi que je
suis sorti de la voiture j'ai senti tout
de suite la différence entre la mère et
la police y ont avec la pollution il ya
plus d'arbres et sans arme napperons
d'une respiration
oui c'est sûr qu'il faut faire quelque
chose parce que sinon il peut y avoir
des animaux qui disparaissent ou alors
ça peut pas me la nature à peu se
décomposer là un gros problème
il faut faire quelque chose et là comme
matin j'ai l'impression qu'elle a pas
beaucoup servi enfin ils ont pris des
résolutions mais quand même je vois pas
vraiment le changement pour l'instant
même c'est pas censé être touchée tout
de suite mais il faudra organiser un peu
plus de nettoyons la nature
essayez de faire un système pour pas
colère s'échappe
on pourrait faire quelque chose comme ça
parce que je vois pas pourquoi les
femmes seraient enfin un roman de
qualité que les hommes on est
normalement est tous égaux
je trouve que c'est pas très intelligent
parce que tout le monde il faut
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
le sexisme sait pas qu'en politique
c'est dans tous les métiers donc si on
voulait vraiment parler de ça faut faire
globalement quoi le président de la
république pourrait par exemple parler
on le montrerai info il pourrait parler
à toute la france de sa de dire qu'il
faut par exemple qu'il faut jamais faire
ça pourrait élire quelqu'un qui
règlerait tous a enfin je suis pas ça
existe déjà une loi contre le sexisme
peut-être mais peut-être punir plus
sévèrement parce que bon juste dire que
c'est mal et tout ça suffira pas faut
vraiment agir
surtout si c'est fait par des
politiciens alors que ce qu'ils sont
censés faire les lois bonjour l'exemple
et avant de refermer ce journal un mot à
présent des sujets que nous développons
à partir de mardi dans notre nouvelle
édition car vous le savez le lundi 16
mai est un jour férié
c'est le lundi de pentecôte nous
reviendrons sur l'inauguration de la
place des douves à voisins le bretonneux
elle aura lieu samedi 14 mai à 11h30 une
inauguration qui intervient après dix
semaines de travaux nous reviendrons
également sur l'un des grands rendez
vous de la saison sportive mort
parisienne samedi 14 et dimanche 15 mai
le parc des sports du goût des clots
accueille la mort pas ivan cup tournoi
international de jeunes footballeurs
près de 900 joueurs vont s'affronter
dans les catégories de denise a eu 17
des équipes venant de belgique et des
pays-bas rencontreront de jeunes joueurs
de maurepas de paris ou encore du loiret
siens et puis il sera aussi question de
cinéma toute la semaine retrouvez une
série de reportages spécialement dédié
aux yvelinois présent au festival de
cannes c'est à présent la fin de cette
édition dans un instant vos idées
sorties et loisirs avec sephora namani
dans le 7-8 week end rendez vous mardi à
18h en direct pour un nouveau journal
ripley de nos reportages émissions sur
le site internet de la chaîne vous
pouvez également nous suivre sur les
réseaux sociaux je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end au revoir